hello gentlemen we're gonna talk about a
video from what culture today 9 most
insane demands famous actors made for
movies but John before we watch this
video from what culture which culture
wanted to give a shout out today to
today's video sponsor viewer reviews.com
people
so what veer reviews is it's a new
social platform that determines how well
you will like a movie based on your
tastes and the films you've reviewed on
the site viewer reviews also helps you
connect with people who share your
passion and taste for movies like we've
said before it's more of a personalised
Rotten Tomatoes tailored to you and your
friends personal cinematic tastes we
just started using viewer reviews and
the matches are pretty spot-on and we've
already got some people following us
over there yeah it's a good opportunity
to try and write a really short review -
it's real easy to get started once you
create an account you'll fill out a
couple basic questionnaires to give the
site a sense for your specific taste and
from there you're ready to start
reviewing movie sharing your taste and
connecting with people so hit that link
in the description box and check out
viewer reviews.com today don't forget to
follow us the real rejects over there
[Music]
dildos and cocaine
on that one sit for a second dildos and
cocaine that's the level rock rating on
on this list robust not your bag you
might as well just pay it out now Bailey
Julia great probably unfair to say that
all Hollywood actors are self-obsessed
endo maniacs because let's face it you
were getting five million dollars per
job you'd probably be unbearable to but
with success comes excess inventory
comes ridiculous stories about film
stars demanding things like dildos and
cocaine and live lobsters and ice bucket
hats in custom one it's just it's a
really good one how many of these I'm
going to the movies number nine
Angelina Jolie demanded a movie studio
pay for Brad Pitt's flying lessons this
is a flimsy one but okay the story goes
that a major studio George could say no
to it which might go some way to
explaining how he gets such lavish
trailer requests granted despite the
fact he was in gravity for a grand total
of like 20 minutes he's still supposedly
requested that a custom Beach hood hot
tub and pride basketball court be built
next to his trailer he just wants to
relax
that's actually not white powder isn't a
books because it was filmed in England
pretty much the last place on earth
you'd ever want to use a hot tub the man
is nuts
quite frankly number seven also wells
game now costume is lined with mink fur
but last ever line that master filmmaker
and cinematic genius Orson Welles
delivered was in transform as the movie
has nothing to do with this list I just
really really love that anyway yeah he
was also quite insane when it came to
film demands and whilst filming the
Black Rose Welles demanded that the
inside of his costume was lying with
incredibly expensive food the inside
which was never once go he was shown on
screen he just really really liked the
feel of it and demanded the studio give
it to him because he was a baller play
number six
Will Smith demanded a double-decker
mobile home and blocked out the Sun so
what would you possess for true story
Will Smith rocked over to the
negotiations four men in black and said
he wouldn't be happy while his greatest
enemy bill providing people with three
liked heat energy
I call this enemy he said to a terrified
panel of movie producers the Sun
retracting a huge section of the board
to reveal a model of the film studio he
went on to say but since the beginning
of time man had learned to destroy the
Sun but he would do the next best thing
walk it out with a massive double-decker
trailer but well they gasped every plant
and tree will die I will take eating and
the studio Sun Dial will be useless
yet their cries fell upon deaf ears and
Smith has his wish to play sir it should
be said local residents who did
literally have to live in its shadow for
the duration of filming number five
Paris Hilton demanded live lobsters just
in case okay
Paris Hilton has expensive tastes I mean
that's pretty much all she's known for
but you think she's at least a food
willing to reign in for a single day and
we're talking really really small here
in buddy cop comedy other guys she
demanded that live lobsters were put on
standby so that even even during filming
should
you get a little peckish she was on set
for one day I'm required that a chef
live lobsters and they trying to house
them in was brought in especially just
in case she wanted to meet them I might
be in love with this one Bruce Willis
was asked to reprise a small role in the
Expendables yeah it should be said that
would have required him to be on set for
four days
his response yeah all right I'm sure
it'll cost you a million dollars that's
1 million dollars per day even by the
modern standards of movie wages that was
considered absolutely mental and he was
promptly told to God number three
Marlon Brando demanded his character
wore an ice bucket as a hat and had his
own personal the guy see you there
you're expecting this entry to primarily
be me calling Marlon Brando crazy or
making fun of her bash men will the
production was on the island of dr.
Moreau but no you might think I'm going
to laugh at the story of Brian they were
arriving on set putting an ice bucket on
his head and being so stubborn in his
refusal to take it off didn't have to be
written into the bill but no you might
think I'm gonna ask questions about the
fact he befriended a dog and refused to
act unless he was written into every
scene but still no instead I'm going to
say with complete honesty that if I am
ever famous and wealthy enough to have
all the logic of a toddler I am 100%
doing it number two Jack Nicholson days
the hard-nosed in cocaine as a friend
apart I told you so during the making of
Martin Scorsese oscar-winning crime
click the departed Nicholson decided
that the movie should include a scene
with a dildo and be his character
snoring cocaine
often actresses art or Saturday as I
call it Martin Scorsese ever the
pragmatic chap relented to Jack's
requests to the point that you can see
both of these things appearing within
the very frames of the finished film is
their artistic merit in going full
method with a 12 inch rubber [ __ ] and a
few grams of Bolivia
I mean probably not but who cares
number one Tom Cruise demanded
custom-made thumb for what I truly truly
wish I was making this one up but no
here we are according to a bunch of
sources Hollywood superstar Tom Cruise
is adamant that once filming action
sequences for pretty much all of his
movies he gets to wear a thong why
exactly this tidbit has become public
knowledge I'm not entirely sure but I
sincerely doubt that there's any water
enjoys the idea of Tom Cruise wearing
thong there's just something so yeah the
zip wire scene in Mission Impossible
wearing a customer thong running away
from you into more of the world's
wrestling with the bad guys in Jack
Reacher falling out was that played in
the movie I do not feel well there we
are
every day's a school day isn't it under
school is absolutely mental let's know
what crazy demands you make in the
comments and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe until next week what Coach
is Adam Clearinghouse not see that I
will forever ruin Tom Cruise action is
the whole time I'll be watching it I'll
be thinking is he wearing that thong
right now kids with the scene I once
thought was cool of now distracted
thinking about it's like I heard Sean
Connery when he would do the driving
scenes and bond he wouldn't wear pants
because it was so hot anytime I see
those scenes I'm like is he wearing
pants in this shot we will see come
Commission impossible day 2018 it's the
whole like focused on something that I
never thought I'd be focused on I guess
it must allow for you to move easier
more freely less [ __ ] like I have so
many questions I was surprised about how
funny this video actually was is I liked
the approach of the narration of taking
it like they're all like crazy Angelina
Jolie demanding a movie studio okay for
breakfast
what new with the movie was the second
that number to flash though maybe was
for something now not even attached if I
was a superstar I'd have one very
specific demand a masseuse onset oh yeah
that would be like my through that one
demand is like get me a masseuse and
have live chickens on set ready to kill
any moment's notice for dinner time oh
yeah I get to kill myself for the crew
we all take a break on any power
I mean hey that's love that's love on
Angelina Jolie's end I just want to hear
the conversation just before that where
the conclusion was all right I want to
call the studio and see if they'll pay
for yes actually find George Clooney's
to be that ridiculous for a superstar
like George Clooney a hot tub a custom
beach it's funny to me hey but it's not
like insane I'm like yeah he's an actor
who likes to chill out it's kind of
insane as this is on the set of gravity
out of all movies he's barely in that
movie yeah if this was like one of the
movies where he was like an Ocean's
Twelve or something and then I'd be like
yeah you gotta see it but he's just
funny ass requests this is sound guy
just wants to relax and it's all he
really cares about everyone else is kind
of sound kind of nutty but it's just
sound like I just want to be able to
chill out it's a nice place to chill a
hot tub with which to woo ladies and
then a basketball court on one I know he
likes play tennis and basketball he's
more like that kind of athlete you know
it sound like a buff kind of athlete who
just likes the game the rock demands
that a gym is built on set for him is
like philosophical like a reason he
needs rail against that's a nutty one to
me sounds like he made it jazzy and they
took it seriously honestly yeah like a
double-decker mobile home sounds like
something a guy like Will Smith who gets
paid twenty million dollars a movie to
do would ask for it probably has people
will show up on set all the time and he
wants to just be lavish whatever but
block out the Sun woo
that was a joke that people just took
away too serious I wonder if they had to
get zoning for that or something I just
wanna know what was in that mobile yeah
like what we're all the decks what was
the first floor was the second floor
what was all there I'm surprised with
the Bruce Willis one that they did not
bring up how Stallone went like pretty
public about that and got pissed at
Bruce Willis he was like tweeting out
about Bruce Willis you know I'm saying
this is how you like lose friends in the
business or whatever is how you have a
career tanked or some crabby talk smack
on it I mean it's not I was treated
terribly at the box office but he was
the only missing actor yeah Harrison
Ford in there even and I think that got
Harrison because they didn't get Bruce
Willis man if they had Bruce Willis in
there that would have been like well
they did it but that just sounds like a
Bruce Willis Eenadu because Bruce Willis
just hates action keep doing them for
money Bruce Willis reminds me of a sad
guy I just imagine a sad dude the
opening of this statement Marlon Brando
two men in his character were an ice
bucket as a hat and has my personal
dwarfed sounded different when you were
sweet well yeah because then you think
he had like a dwarf like waiting on him
or like they just watered yeah you
imagine like a dwarf serving - yeah yeah
just like someone to fancy mall my door
fish limbs
yeah but they said in the video that he
befriended a dwarf and then wanted him
featured in every scene and wanted to
make sure he was in every scene which is
kind of cool pretty cool especially at
that time the only really popular little
person actor is Peter Dinklage now I
know and we can see past the whole
little person yeah yeah and like you
know he's just allowed to be that
character and I get in front so it's
cool for Marlon Brando who you know they
didn't accept his Godfather Oscar
he just had some Indian woman go up
there and talk about Native American
rights and how they're representative
movies of all the movies like I don't
feel like that's too hard dating no no
no the ice buckets a little kooky why
why did you need that Jack Nicholson
making a weird demand sound like it's
all in character though the dildo scene
I remember that when he whips out the
the porn theater it's the front of Matt
Damon I was funny and surprising it
makes sense within context that he has a
porn theater and stuff and he wants to
play a joke on him that's a funny thing
it's a black hill the cocaine part was
that real cocaine that's what I couldn't
figure that's what I couldn't figure out
either and that's what I was very much
like I bet you know it's jack I'm sure
somebody can make it happen yeah I
wouldn't put it past somebody to where
like if he wanted to do it and if would
have made the scene amazing or whatever
like because I remember that scene and
it really seemed like he was on drugs
but I'm like that's just good acting a
makeup wandering and really yeah I guess
the implication is if it's a good
cocaine and a dildo I guess the
implication is it's cocaine well this
was one of the funniest videos you guys
have put together what culture yeah I
really laughed a lot during this thank
you for doing that you guys can
subscribe to what culture subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and you can check us
out on patreon full-length music video
and TV show react including some anime
right now go over there check it out
weekly Q&A love to have you
last but not least make sure to check us
out on viewer reviews.com follow us at
the real rejects over there join that
community